Kenyans at this Hospital in kisumu
County light candles to remember those
who died during anti-government protests
recently they say police attacked
protesters demonstrating against a High
Cost of Living and the imposition of new
taxes
some of the injured remain in hospital
many have gunned short wounds we came to
see so that we are certain that there is
there are people here that were killed
as a result of the police totality
people who are here say this is a day of
remembrance they want to remember those
who died and those who are still in
hospital they also say they don't trust
the police they say they want Justice
[Music]
at this Homestead prepared to bury a
relative George odhiambo was shot in one
of the most violent confrontations
between security forces and protesters
I feel so much pain his death was so
unexpected I had my son on Thursday
morning and then he was gone I'm still
in shock I'll never see him again
opposition leaders in the capital
Nairobi also held vigils they accused
the government of ethnic profile and
ordering police to use excessive force
on protesters
the interior Ministry accused some
politicians of inciting riots in what
the government called economic sabotage
President William Ruto says he's ready
to meet with opposition leader raila
odinga but similar talks have failed
before I don't believe that Mr Ruto is
serious at all he is double speak one
side
it suits him he talks very nicely and
says oh I'm ready for the talks anytime
the other time his people saying that oh
Mr dinga and this group just want to
have a handshake so that they can't be
able to share the cake
[Music]
back in kisumu this Mona say they just
want answers Catherine soy Al Jazeera
kisumu Western Kenya